So hopefully, this quiz is a little bit easier than the last one we did. What
we're trying to do first, is just identify the terms that have w in them. So,
going through our equation up here, we see 36w and 51w. And we can just fill
those in to these first two slots.
Remember that it doesn't matter which order we write them in. It doesn't matter
if we write 36w or 51w first, because of the commutative property of addition.
Next we need to identify the n terms, so those are the two that are left, 22n
and 50n. And we just want to write those in these two slots. Again, order does
not matter because we're just going to add everything together. I'm just going
to put the 22n first, since 22 happens to be my favorite number. The last step
to make this a fully blown equation, is to add in our plus or minus signs
between the terms. Here, in the top equation, every term is positive. We don't
see any negative signs here. So that means that each of these signs is going to
be a plus sign. When we switch terms around, there's no change to the value of
each term.
Nothing is going to become negative that used to be positive. So the only thing
that's different about this bottom equation from this top equation is the order
that we've written the terms in.